the left is probably hoping the hubbub
over the Mike Flynn guilty plea will
drown out this story but a group of
congressmen is demanding at the FBI
investigate alleged special treatment of
Hillary Clinton during its investigation
into her private email server
Congressman Matt Gaetz of Florida sent a
letter to FBI director Christopher Rea
asking the bureau to explain its
decision to investigate Clinton with a
quote small team what does that mean
the congressman joins us now congressman
gates you've been all over this people
are saying oh you just don't understand
when they say special investigation in
small team that's just routine kind of
lingo so you're making a big deal over
nothing well Laurel we now have smoking
gun evidence that Hillary Clinton got
special treatment and it's important to
provide context we've got Loretta Lynch
on the tarmac with Bill Clinton
we've got Loretta Lynch telling James
Comey to call this a matter and not an
investigation then we've got James Comey
sucking this up to headquarters and
keeping the investigators in the
Washington DC office away from the
Clinton investigation and then he drafts
the exoneration statement before even
conducting the interview in six days the
FBI director Christopher ray will be
before the House Judiciary Committee and
we need answers because Hillary Clinton
didn't deserve special treatment she
should have been treated like every
American and now we know she was not do
you think that when they say special
treatment and the way they designated it
it was just from what you can see with
all the things you just laid out it was
just kind of soft-pedaling it or
shortcutting it or we know the
conclusion let's just put some window
dressing on it so it looks like it's
official but let's wrap this baby up as
fast as possible is that what you're
getting at
well that's what the evidence suggests
and when you look at the recent
documents released about the tarmac
meeting between Loretta Lynch and Bill
Clinton the FBI was more worried about
spin control and public relations and
punishing the person that released this
information than they were about the
improper conduct of the Attorney General
of the United States and so time and
again we see from the Obama era that
they were determining the outcomes
before actually conducting the
investigation that's not what the
American people deserve and that's why
we're gonna fight for a real
investigation congressmen weren't they
also desperate to find out who leaked
the Clinton meeting on the tarmac with
Loretta Lynch absolutely recently
discovered emails show that the FBI was
very concerned about who let the
American people know that Loretta Lynch
was meeting with Bill Clinton but they
weren't at all concerned about the fact
that the meeting had occurred and had
jeopardized this very critical
investigation so we're really seeing a
circumstance where the FBI the Lynch
Department of Justice was engaged in a
cover-up of their activities all the
same time they were determining the
outcome of the Hillary Clinton
investigation before actually doing it
all right congressman gates thanks for
that update